Richard McKee is with Crime Stoppers of
Nevada and has worked on the internet
crimes against children task force he's
concerned now but just how much personal
information children as well as adults
are sharing on social media and how
predators are exploiting that
as the technology changed the the
Predators would change their habits
their their tactics their their
techniques and they would adapt to take
advantage of the latest in technology
this is especially true of social media
where my key warrants it's easy to
create fake profiles all you have is
that picture maybe you get a phone call
but how do you know that that person is
who they say they are scrolling through
his computer but he shows us a website
that generates fake photos this picture
here is uh does not is not actually a
real person there's also a website McKee
pointed us to that creates an email
address without you having to give your
real name or address and then you can
turn that into a social media account
because now you've got a valid email
address with no name these tools are
concerning to law enforcement with the
task of protecting children kids aren't
the only ones being targeted however
adults often fall prey to online scams
according to the FBI people lost 6.9
billion dollars to internet crimes in
2021 still McKee says it's easier for
kids to be manipulated and groomed
online becoming victims of human
trafficking the human trafficking impact
on a person's life especially a young
person's life is is so difficult for the
average person to imagine
now McKee says if you see something say
something if you have any additional
tips for Crime Stoppers of Nevada and
want to report a case of what you
believe is human trafficking you can
call them at
702-385-55 of course you can also stay
anonymous